the accusations against besieged Alabama
Senate candidate Roy Moore have reached
sufficient fever pitch to attract
blood-sucking harpie Gloria Allred
brutal new testimony just this hour from
an alleged victim that said Moore's
attackers on the Left have won
intractable desiccated undead obstacle
to their moralizing Hillary Clinton my
third cousin once removed we will
analyze love in the time of fake news
then roaming millennial amber Athey and
paul bois his eminence himself joined
the panel of deplorable z' to discuss
short fat kim jeong-hoon why you should
boycott Keurig and a new york times
writers passionate defense of racial
segregation the new york times is a
former newspaper now a former newspaper
tomorrow a former newspaper forever
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
that gloria allred press conference came
at about 20 minutes ago came out as we
were ready to go on air there is a woman
who's now alleging that when she was 15
she was molested by Roy Moore was sexual
assault there was nothing in central
about it so this leaves Roy Moore with
only one option he has to come at his
gay he has to choose now to live as a
gay man we will have Christopher Plummer
replace him as the Republican nominee in
Alabama that's I think that's the only
way that we can handle this and still
possibly win this seat Plummer 2017
that's the way to do it that there's
your write-in campaign right there
this Allred presser if you haven't seen
it is savage it is brutal the the
Democrats have played this opposition
research perfectly with accusations that
haven't come out for 40 years they've
just played it right up to the election
they've built up they've let him bury
himself and this is really rough the
woman's name is Beverly young Nelson she
says that when she was 15 she was a
beauty prep pageant queen who was
working at a diner and Roy Moore would
come in there he was the DA for the
county at the time he would come in he
was always hitting on her asking her to
go out with him she said no one time he
waited for her to leave the restaurant
and offered to give her a ride home
because her boyfriend wasn't there
according to this woman he drove her
around back where there were no lights
and made a move tried to lock the door
fondled her eventually she said no
fought back long enough that she fell
out of the car he pushed her out of the
car and said you're just a child I'm the
DA no one will ever believe you your
mother will never believe you apparently
her sister attests to this at the time
some friends she and her husband
crucially voted for Trump so this is one
point she said I'm willing to go under
oath on this this isn't a Republican
Democrat thing I and my husband both
both voted for Trump this is really
really bad much worse than the
Washington Post story much worse than
unnamed women some women on the record
some women off alleging weird conduct
when they
were 16 or 17 or 18 this is brutal it's
graphic it's going to be run on every TV
in Alabama for the next few weeks Mitch
McConnell by the way before this press
conference had already called for Roy
Moore to drop out of the race the White
House is backed off of Roy Moore you'll
remember Trump didn't endorse Roy Moore
in the primary he endorsed Luther
strange the primary opponent here is
more defending himself
now this clip is from before the Gloria
Allred presser today but I imagine he
won't really change this tune very much
this is Roy Moore's defense Washington
Post published rather yet another attack
on my character and reputation in a
desperate attempt to stop my political
campaign for the United States Senate
these attacks involve a minor and
they're completely false and untrue I
want to make it clear to the media
present and the people president I have
not provided alcohol beverages alcoholic
beverages beer or anything else till
minor I have not been guilty of sexual
misconduct with anyone
I've been investigated more than any
other person in this country to think
that grown women would wait 40 years to
come before right before an election to
bring charges is absolutely unbelievable
why now the Democrats and the
Republicans establishment know the
importance of this election in fact most
people in America know the importance of
this election they see it as a prelude
to the elections coming in 2018 it may
very well determine the future of our
country my opponent is 11 points behind
that came out just days before this
article came out they're desperate
this article is a prime example of fake
news fake news that's Roy Moore's story
and he's sticking to it decent enough
defense what else is he going to say he
can't cop to it then he loses the race
he can't drop out now no one's gonna win
in his place it'll just go to Democrats
so he's saying this is all fake news and
don't worry about it a much harder case
to make now that we have a woman on the
record who's apparently a Republican
apparently a trump voter who's coming
out and making these accusations now
Gloria Allred is not the only blood
sucking harpy involved in all of this
there is one intractable problem for
Democrats and that is Hillary Clinton so
Chris Hayes stop clock is Right twice a
day MSNBC Chris Hayes came out and
tweeted this over the weekend quote as
gross and cynical and hypocritical as
the writes what about Bill Clinton's
stuff is it's also true that Democrats
and the center-left are overdue for a
real reckoning with the allegations
against him read this account he's
talking about Juanita Broderick in light
of all we've been hearing and reading
this last month and ask yourself if it
is credible now he's talking about this
accusation by a woman named Juanita
Broderick that says that Bill Clinton
raped her decades ago and Hillary knew
about it and Hillary pressured her to
keep quiet and this has come out for
years with the with the Clintons now we
have Democrats finally copping and
saying well maybe that's the case why
are they doing it might be true that
they want to get Hillary out of here
they're pulling at Donna Brazile they
want to toss her under the bus
get rid of Hillary Clinton as fast as we
can move on to better pastures for 2020
but if that's the case it takes the wind
out of their sails of all of them
realizing they've been saying well we
can how could you possibly not call for
ROI more to get out of the race to drop
out to go away this was before the most
recent accusations when it was just a
Washington Post story how could you not
it's awful we're the moral voice of
America but just a year ago they tried
to make a woman who pressured and
intimidated and bullied and smeared her
husband's alleged rape victims they
tried to make her president so much for
all that moralizing where's that high
horse where was all that moralism a year
ago when you were trying to make that
woman who's accused of worse things when
you were trying to make her president
you know the guy I blame most and all
this obviously we can go back and forth
the Clinton thing is a really nice tool
at the Wrights disposable because we can
say well look folks that political races
are complicated and you know there are
more reasons than just accusations from
40 years ago to vote for a guy probably
that arguments not going to hold anymore
after the most recent presser in
accusations but we'll see what happens
the guy blame most in all this is Luther
strange the primary opponent the Trump
endorsed and and the establishment
endorsed in Alabama he failed as a
campaign his campaign failed to dig up
all of this dirt unless all of these
accusations are totally fabricated and
again I wouldn't put it past Democrats
to totally fabricated accusations weeks
before an election when you're down by
double digits but unless they are
totally fabricated loser Luther Strange
blew it because he could have found all
of this I've been to meetings like this
you go to the other campaign you say we
have this information they say okay they
decide whether or not to drop out if
they don't privately drop out then you
release the information it goes public
and then you see what's happening to Roy
Moore now would have happened two months
ago the the strange campaign didn't do
it it's really frustrating we might lose
the Senate seat now it looks like we're
probably going to really really awful
and all of this said sex scandals are a
hallmark of American politics I think it
were very it's easy to say well now what
has happened Trump has reduced the
nation to rubble or Bill Clinton has
reduced the nation to rub her now we
have all these sex scandals but it used
to be so nice and weed court people and
it was hunky-dory and gentlemanly and
chivalrous not true they've been sex
scandals have been a hallmark of
American politics since the beginning
Alexander Hamilton
Washington's aide de camp and the
founder of the Treasury Department he
cuckold in a man named James Reynolds in
1791 this came out it damaged his
political career a mid 19th century
South Carolina senator from the
nullifier party had a gay relationship
in college and then he had a little
dalliance as he said with his two
teenage nieces he couldn't run for
re-election the next time he was
re-elected to Senate a few years later
Senator David Walsh a Democrat from
Massachusetts visited gay Nazi brothels
in America you can go to gay brothels
you can go to Nazi brothels you cannot
go to gay Nazi brothels that's a step
too far
Supreme Court Justice William O Douglas
was thrice married cheated on all of the
wives and molested airline stewardesses
there's nothing really new about all of
this that said it's going to have
consequences and this might have been
the nail in the coffin for mr. Moore now
we've got to analyze all of this we have
to bring on roaming millennial with us
since the beginning Romi millennial to
give us expert advice
amber Athey from The Daily Caller and
his eminence the one and only Paul
Cardinal voix panel thank you for being
here I appreciate it my pleasure
rubbing is one more finished I'm having
a lot of trouble with this I'm someone
who thought I was extremely hypocritical
when during the election Democrats
turned a blind eye to Bill Clinton and I
also was someone who was very skeptical
about a lot of the allegations that were
coming out against Trump with that being
said I'm trying to look at this fairly
and objectively and not see more as a
Republican but rather just someone who's
having all of these allegations against
him that you know right now are hearsay
but I mean it's not just one person at
this point I don't think it's good for
the Republican image if he stays in this
race and if people continue to stand by
him I mean this isn't to say that I
think he's definitely guilty I don't
think we should abandon presumption of
innocence just because this is a
political matter and you know we're
fighting for the elections in 2018 but
at the same time yeah this doesn't look
good and for a lot of people Republicans
already have the image whether it's true
or not I don't think it's true of being
soft on men who sexually harassed and
sexually abused women and I I don't
think Roy Moore is good for the party
right now
that might be the case but if he isn't
guilty then should we allow ourselves to
be bullied by Gloria Allred if he isn't
guilty they're all these accusations
let's dump him under the bus but what
what if he isn't guilty then doesn't
that set a precedent for all campaigns
that's it it doesn't look good for more
on in this particular but in the general
if they're just unsubstantiated if we
don't have a lot of evidence should we
really automatically believe Gloria
Allred in her clients I don't believe
these women without evidence I think if
you're making allegations against
someone it's up to you
you have burden of proof to substantiate
your claims but at the same time if we
are actually interested in pushing
forward conservative principles through
electing legislators then people
including Roy Moore himself need to
realize that this looks bad now I think
the clip you mentioned that he was still
I think 11 points ahead of his opponent
so maybe for Alabama voters this isn't a
big deal but I think in all these
elections the candidates themselves
often end up overlooking the point of
this the point of this is to get someone
with conservative principles into office
and to make people more willing in the
future to vote for Republicans this
doesn't do that sure
amber I think a lot of people in the
Republican side who are keeping mama and
Roy Moore or who are even defending or
anymore are saying look I don't care I
don't care about 40 years ago I don't
care about his personal life
I want more freedom and I want less
tyranny and I want more of my own money
and I want less government and I want
conservative social policy and I don't
want crazy revolutionary social policy
and it's a raiser than majority in the
Senate right now do you think that that
argument holds water or do we have to
hold this guy accountable if the
accusations are at all credible and tell
them well we're gonna lose this race but
it's better than having someone who has
committed these crimes in the Senate
well I don't think it would be very
conservative to not hold people
accountable for their crimes considering
how much we believe in due process and
how we believe that the law applies
equally to everyone regardless of
whether or not that person is in a
position of power and I think in this
case you know it's it's important to
note that these stories are
very well source the Washington Post
piece noted that the woman who made
these accusations had told their their
mothers and their sister at the time and
then the woman who just came out had
this yearbook note she had a photo of a
yearbook note that Roy Moore apparently
left her he signed it love Roy Moore da
and then he called her beautiful in it
and I know if my parents saw that type
of message in a yearbook from a thirty
year old man when I was 15 16 years old
they would go nuclear I mean gosh my dad
would probably be in prison by now so I
think it's important to look at all of
these accusations as a whole and not
just you know each part on their own
mr. bois your eminence should Roy Moore
get out of the race it's certainly
looking like that
last week when the allegations first
broke I said to myself okay I'm gonna
give it a couple days see if the
allegations remain credible and if they
hold up to scrutiny I certainly wasn't
one to get quicking with the Washington
Post or even believe them right off the
bat but it very quickly is looking like
the allegations are credible the one
that came forward today is even more
credible like amber said the yearbook
yeah I think he I think that Roy Moore
is probably guilty of these and I also
have a friend of mine who I won't name
who's dealt with Roy Moore in the past
previously said when she was 18 he gave
her his personal email address which she
felt was a little bit inappropriate and
odd at the time so the email address I
want to get him on the show come on pass
it along man I'm not cute enough and I'm
not eating that so yeah I he I think he
needs to drop out when you've lost paul
bois you have both was slightly to the
right of Genghis Khan and Attila the Hun
the Vox Dei himself really bad not
looking good he might have to finally
call this thing quits but we'll see
they're pretty tough down there in
Alabama maybe I'll say I got two words
for you Washington Post and they're not
happy birthday who knows okay we have a
lot of news to get to we have to get to
the Democrats and the
full-throated endorsement of segregation
we have to get to fake news from the New
York Times as separate fake news from
the New York Times and we also have to
get to the boycott Keurig campaign not
just because the coffee isn't good but
because we're defending Sean Hannity
before all of that I'm sorry I know you
guys want to definitely see more amber
and roaming millennial and you'll
tolerate more paul bois but
unfortunately unless you subscribe to
The Daily wire you can't do that so you
have to go to the daily wired.com right
now and by the way the reason to
subscribe just today is tomorrow is the
conversation be sure to tune in it's our
next episode of the conversation Tuesday
November 14th that's tomorrow
5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring
you guessed it little ol me the
conversation will stream live on The
Daily wire website Facebook page and
YouTube channel it will be free for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
can ask the questions so subscribe today
you get to ask me all of the most
important questions I'll give you my
homemade cough fa recipe there there's a
lot of information that you can get out
of this so do that subscribe right now
join the conversation if you subscribe
it's ten bucks a month 100 dollars for
an annual membership what do you get you
get me you get the under Clavin sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show yada yada yada
yada you get folks the leftist tears
tumblr now this is a little bit of
speculation here but if it turns out
that these Roy Moore accusations aren't
true if he stays in this race you're
gonna need to buy 25 daily wire
subscriptions you were gonna it's going
to be flooding everywhere already just
from Twitter in the New York Times
you'll you'll have a steady supply
vintage 2017 so go over there right now
is the most coveted most coveted tumbler
for drinking leftist years in the entire
country so go over daily wire.com we
were right back
the New York Times this is the most this
is the most the height of irony the best
story to come out of New York Times in a
while the New York Times is suing in
Manhattan woman for pretending to be a
New York Times reporter so a fake news
outlet is suing woman a woman for saying
that she a fake fake reporter she's a
fake fake journalist which I think makes
her a real journalist which means she
should sue the New York Times for all of
their fake news this is a lot like
inception it's a woman named Contessa
bourbon
she's been masquerading as a New York
Times reporter at events at the
Brookings Institution on Twitter threat
social media she's used it to talk to
congressional staff to get into events
and they're very upset because they're
saying that this woman is damaging their
decent reputation they're saying that
they have a fine reputation and business
and a distinctive quality to their
journalism and I can give everybody
listening and and here a minute to
chuckle and guffaw and spit out their
drinks very commonly before answering
this roaming why on earth would anyone
want to be associated with the New York
Times that's what I was just wondering
myself I mean if you're gonna go out
there and just pretend to be something
you're not wise New York Times reporter
asked why would you the New York Times
it's like yeah I'm I I'm an unemployed
bum ya know I'm an unemployed I'm gonna
get sued by the unemployed bum guild in
the country doesn't make any sense
this maybe she was hoping that I guess
internally their own fact-checking as to
who was working for ku or was actually
was as vigorous as their regular
fact-checking for their stories I don't
know it's a mystery to us all she'll
probably get promoted if they use their
normal fact-checking she'll probably
become at least to you they are the
opinion page editor or something before
the year is out mister Bois once you
have finished laughing and deploying and
comically spitting out your drink
doesn't this woman have a strong defense
if she plays insanity oh my god I really
don't know what's more insane the fact
that the woman was posing as a reporter
the fact that she thought the New York
Times was respectable enough to posed to
do it so if I were a judge and I heard
the insanity plea I'd be
yeah yeah I think the fact that you
thought the New York Times was the
organization you were gonna pose as yeah
that's that's a pretty strong case for
insanity that's fair enough now you've
heard it from the the supreme judge
himself Vox Dei Paula Cardinal blah
speaking of the New York Times on
Saturday
ikaw and yank I'm sure I'm triggering
people in micro aggressing by
mispronouncing that asked in the New
York Times quote can my children be
friends with white people I'll save you
the trouble of reading the piece no the
answer is no according to this writer a
full-throated defense of racial
segregation from this New York Times
writer roaming has the New York Times
always been this regressive and
ridiculous or you know as Andrew Klavan
says is in a former newspaper did it
used to be a good place and then it just
recently got hollowed out by crazy
leftists no you know what I think I
think the New York Times is in the right
of this I mean first you know black
people white people are being friends
then what's next
you know black and white married couples
mixed-race children where will it end
times exactly they're there right and
taking a stand against this editorial
editor George Wallace will not stand for
this right but I think it's actually
this is great because for a long time
people on the right people are who are
conservatives have been using the term
regressive and actually painting these
people for what they are you know almost
Pro racism Pro segregation and for a
while frankly we've looked a little bit
crazy but I think it's coming to the
point now where more and more people are
starting to realize that there is this
underlying narrative of almost anti
whiteness Pro segregation they really
are in every way regressive in their
ideology and I I'm actually at least
relieved that more and more people are
gonna find out about this because of
this and I think the New York Times has
remained to too many people a credible
outlet and I think I'm glad this is
happening mr. hua this seems to be a
step backward certainly for race
relations they seem to have taken a step
backward over the last 20 years
obviously there are many things that we
could blame for this the left likes to
blame
that's their term a reaction against a
black president or black people getting
some new rights the right rightly points
to multiculturalism terrible revisionist
history's people being ignorant and
being uneducated it from secondary
schooling through colleges what is to
blame what cultural factor what
political factor is to blame for the
backward step in race relations it's 50
years of being inundated with identity
politics Michael I mean unfortunately as
much as we want to as much as we Revere
and rightly revere dr. Martin Luther
King I'm afraid he is not the one who
he's not who won the the the occasional
man yeah on the cultural battle he is
not I have the Civil Rights Act passed
yes and that's a very good thing but
when it came to the actual a cultural
battle and the views and the way we talk
about day to day I that went to Malcolm
X and in the Black Panthers that is the
predominant view that whites and blacks
cannot in any way coexist unless there's
some serious measure taken on behalf of
whites that just I don't even know what
it is at this point but yeah that that's
essentially what the view here is it's
it's the Malcolm X Black Panther view of
race relations that we cannot get along
we cannot recognize each other's
humanity a I'm completely at a loss and
we can debate it all day long but really
New York Times and this man who
published this piece which really should
be titled how I teach my son to be a
racist
there's no way to debate with him
they're lost in a broken ideology and
the only way to defeat them is on the
cultural sphere and that's it and the
left they just use Martin Luther King's
name they just use his name and they
hollow him out you'll notice they always
refer to him as dr. Martin Luther King
but they don't refer to him as Reverend
Martin Luther King you know the thing
that makes him a doctor it's not like
he's an ophthalmologist right he said
he's a theologian he's a preacher and
they take the Jesus out of him and but
there are two figures there's Martin
Luther King who comes from a Baptist
Christian tradition and there's
Malcolm X who comes from the Nation of
Islam tradition and there's the
non-violence there's God who's subdues
himself to logic and reason and there is
Wrath and chicken Simon coming home to
roost and violence in the streets and
and the left the left always uses Martin
Luther King's name there was uses
picture but in their rhetoric in their
action and their policy prescription
they certainly seem to side with Malcolm
X they certainly seem to side side with
the forces of racial division amber can
your child be friends with white people
I guess yours can but it is the
fundamental thesis of this piece is
there any merit to it at all the the
thesis that America is so inherently
racist and it has never corrected its
inherent racism and its inherent
oppression and therefore kids need to
watch out little black kids need to
watch out for the cops they need to
watch out for white people who will
betray them is there any shred of
reality to this no I don't that there is
and unfortunately a what we know now is
that a lot of racism has learned it's
not inherent to individuals and this New
York Times writer has decided that he's
going to teach his children to be racist
and to continue this awful trend and
there's a famous quote that goes
something like the the oppressed
eventually become the oppressors in this
case I think that's what a lot of the
there were aggressive left is seeking to
do there's so much a you're on that side
over slavery and and various systemic
racism that now their goal is to go
ahead and oppress well gay people in
some kind of sixth-sense of twisted
justice there there is certainly images
of this in even Columbus Day you know on
Columbus Day we talked about the history
of mr. Columbus and they're one of the
reasons that Columbus Day became
celebrated in the United States it was
celebrated in 1892 the 400th anniversary
of his expedition but it wasn't
celebrated on the 300th anniversary of
the expedition and the reason is that a
year earlier the largest mass lynching
in US history was taken up against
Sicilians it was actually Sicilian
Americans who were the object of this
lynching 11 of them were
and then italian-americans pushed for
this holiday because Columbus was a
Italian guy he probably would have
called himself Italian he would have
called himself Genovese a or Spanish or
something but we do see that coming back
certainly time and time again all right
enough of the fake a New York Times I
can't I can't take any more there's the
most New York Times I've read in years
probably it was - you sure I am the
subscriber I'm the last driver to the
New York Times but I'm just kidding I
would never pay them anything there is
another great story that went around
Twitter this weekend which is a boycott
Keurig Americans are boycotting Keurig
after a Media Matters Soros coordinated
effort caused the coffee maker to dump
sean hannity show
here's Americans reacting look what I
found peace that's good this is why you
got to subscribe folks that I want to
replay that I'm the whole rest of the
Damned just gonna be playing that video
clip so Keurig pulls out of Hannity
because for no reason by the way Hannity
gave really more a fairly tough
interview but they decided to pounce on
him at Media Matters which is a George
Soros funded attack dog group and now
Americans are boycotting it looks like
Keurig may reverse its decision roaming
is it distasteful for conservatives to
boycott just like lefties do it's much
funnier they're much more clever about
how they do it the left is always
shrieking you have to stop buying this
product and meanwhile the right is like
taking golf clubs
to it and making funny videos about it
is it distasteful should we be engaging
in these tactics or should we leave
coffee on politicised well that's a
great question and I firmly believe that
coffee should not be political I don't
think you know I don't think our ice
cream needs to be political I don't
think our clothing needs to be political
but at the same time we have to ask
ourselves are the consumers the ones who
are making this political or is curing
the one that started making this
political by withdrawing their
sponsorship that's a hard question but I
think consumers are totally in the right
to support brands who they feel align
more with their worldview and again I'm
not saying that conservatives should be
so sensitive and you know these special
snowflakes they get mad at brands if
they do something they don't like but at
the same time you know I don't think
Keurig is necessarily the biggest
culprit of this I think Ben and Jerry's
is really the quintessential
representative of a leftie company who
kind of forces their political views on
people in that case I think it's
completely justified and fine for
consumers to say no I don't want to
sponsor this mister wah I know that the
left is constantly demonizing the evil
corporations Bernie Sanders talked about
the millionaires and the billionaires of
the corporate class is corporate America
does it lean left or does it lean right
left I mean what to say okay they're not
full-blown socialists and since they
want the government to seize control
their operations
they're just crony capitalists yes
they're just crony capitalists but yes
in terms of everything social yeah
they're pretty left I mean in terms of
traditional morality same-sex marriage
yeah as far to the left as you can get
and in terms of abortion that gets a
little bit more dicey you know with
places like Starbucks and of course
Target who are all in for that other
corporations maybe not so much but I
mean for the most part yes corporate
America is against Christians is against
Orthodox Jews is against anybody who
holds anything traditional and doesn't
want to get involved in line with sexual
revolution so yep sad
I always I always bring on Paul Bois to
cheer me up you know I always just so
Paul boy yeah it's a nice day out it's
sunshiny right it's terrible all right
all right well this this last knew I had
to end on a good news story I had to end
on the greatest news story from the
entire weekend it was a single tweet
from our dear leader President Trump on
his Asia trip quote this is this is
after Kim jong-un apparently called
Trump old our president responded in a
very diplomatic very American way why
would Kim jong-un insult me by calling
me old when I would never call him short
and fat oh well I try so hard to be his
friend and maybe someday that will
happen amber the left expectedly went
nuts and which was probably the point of
this entire tweet is this the greatest
moment of trump's presidency including
the appointment of new york or such yeah
so when this tweet happened i was
sitting around drinking beers with
friends and I think we all laughed for a
solid 20 minutes straight I mean it my
third day of laughing was perfect
backhanded insult you could ever imagine
and the fact that it's from the
president just makes it a million times
better this is by far top 10 Donald
Trump tweets of all time you know
they're saying now that he's he's
immature and reckless and impulsive
because he heard that he called him fat
he just tweeted this out
I clearly these people have been missing
the last two years of Donald Trump's
political career you know the entirety
of his political career it this clearly
seems to me to have a strategic
advantage which is that you have to back
up American credibility you have to
build American credibility both in
action both and shows a military force
in shows of diplomatic arrangements and
in the way you speak so you have this
little tin pat Tim pot fat dictator with
nuclear weapons in violation of
countless u.s. and you know UN treaties
and resolutions and he's calling this
guy old and there's our president
doesn't blink calls him short and fat
and tells him where to go you know in
not so many words
roaming am I just kidding myself or is
this a strategically smart way to
respond to this guy you know I'm kidding
myself that's
Donald Trump's Twitter account I don't
know if this is strategic it's
definitely hilarious though and I think
you know there are teenage girls
everywhere learning some tips from
Donald about how you properly conduct a
Twitter flame war it's pretty grand
actually just I think it was after that
tweet he went off on the haters and I
think it's just great that the President
of the United States is taking time out
of his busy schedule to call out the
haters on Twitter it's great
it does harken back to I think it was
two years ago when he said happy new
years to all even to the losers and the
haters he has one of the highest IQs and
everybody knows it but I feel bad for
you it's not your fault that you were
born effed up he used the longer word
that that is that's the president he
obviously he really is a poet in this
medium I'm not being facetious I'm not
being hyperbolic he uses language in
this medium so effectively mr. Bois is
it going to start World War three just
hunker down right now I'd be hard
pressed to say if a tweet from President
Trump cost World War three or are you
gonna feel foolish when that building
behind you blows up because of it yeah
yeah I would feel very very foolish but
I don't I I think this tweet was
brilliant it's just it's the way you got
a deal with men like kim jeong-hoon and
other men of his caliber is just to deal
with them on their level and that this
is exactly the way to hit it at them and
just the show you know what you are a
small individual on this stage you are
not big and we're not gonna treat you
with the level of respect that you think
you deserve I love it yeah I really love
it - I don't think it's mature I think
it's strategic I don't care how absurd
roaming millennial thinks I am being
right now so when the bombs start flying
of course panel feel free to come hunker
down here I am basically in a cellar I'm
in the cellar of the ben shapiro show so
come on down we'll lock it up we have
endless supplies of cough fa obviously a
bunch of MREs and ammo so feel free to
come over here panel always good to see
you
amber Athey from The Daily Caller
roaming millennial from the youtubes and
his eminence Paul Cardinal
that is our entire show today I should
point out if you want to get a little
kick we're talking about Twitter
flamewars Montel Williams tweeted an
article that I wrote over the weekend
you know that he used to be on daytime
TV and he had that show with the psychic
and reading DNA results and whatever and
anyway he tweeted at this article that I
said and said it was the least
intelligent thing he'd ever read and so
we were going back and forth and I said
well you're welcome to come on my show
if you'd like to not just insult me but
actually debate the merits of these
things and he totally chickened out so
if you want to send him a little tweet
laughing about that be my guest it was
pretty funny you can find it on the
Twitter timelines do you have to
subscribe to the conversation tomorrow
it's gonna be a lot of fun I've got my
nose in the book studying all of the
important facts to change your life
forever and I'll see you then we'll have
a show first
I am Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Doyle show come back tomorrow we'll do
it all again
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
marshal Benson executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by alex is and
Garo audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Jessa of era and
our Associate Producer is Bailey Lynn
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
for word publishing production copyright
for word publishing 2017